large language models have continued to
impress over the last few years
especially in the last year or so while
performance model size architecture and
data sets have all had just massive
improvements one thing has stayed
relatively the same during the last year
or so and arguably since the very
beginning of llm explosions the maximum
context length most models right now are
about 2048 some are up to 4K and very
few anything beyond this and when large
language models first came out I mean it
was numbers maybe like 512 or something
like that but the models themselves were
far inferior and also the actual model
was just way smaller and while models
and techniques and everything have
gotten much better the contact size
really remains unchanged now 2048 tokens
is not nothing this is a 2048 token
example initially this feels extremely
large if you have sufficiently
intelligent models like gpt4 for example
2048 tokens Can often feel pretty
comfortable for a lot of tasks but even
then one thing I keep personally running
into is I want to use this intelligence
for more than just you know simple
prompts I want to use it for just plain
larger projects with a lot more going on
in this way you're likely to want to be
able to feed in a lot of data into the
context without necessarily needing to
fine-tune the model in a sense you're
kind of trying to replace a large
context or you're trying to replace
fine-tuning a model with a very large
context
maybe I want a model to respond to
emails or tweets or write code I very
quickly hit a wall with the 2048 token
limit or even a 4K limit I've also been
trying to use large language models to
help me parse through research papers
and to just kind of keep an eye on
Research that's coming out find
similarities find differences find new
issues and all that and here very much
especially 2048 won't even get you
through a single paper and most of the
time neither will 4K now there are
techniques and tricks to get around this
by sort of summarizing and vectorizing
information but I have yet to see a
really superb implementation that
actually solves the problem in this way
next there are some models of course
that have larger contacts so the open
source MPT models for example come to
mind mpt30b going up to 16 000 tokens
sort of or even the amputee story writer
going up to 65 000 plus tokens with
claims up to 84 000 tokens
sort of because not all context windows
are really equal I think there's a
reason why even chat gbt is still
released with only up to 16k tokens and
that was relatively recently for example
as you try to stretch out attention we
wind up having three just major issues
the first is can you actually fit the
attention into your available GPU memory
so this is either a this is a Boolean
answer it's yes or no either it fits or
it doesn't as you continue to increase
the contact size the GPU memory is taxed
uh similarly so the larger that that
memory the much more the larger the
context or the memory let's say for the
model the much larger your GPU memory
requirement is
the second issue is are you prepared for
the exponentially increasing processing
time for that greater amount of tokens
in context
and again this number two is what is
conceivably stopping most models uh from
achieving very large context Windows the
processing time uh translates directly
to training time it translates directly
to inference time actually using the
model putting it into production uh
while time isn't the same as number one
number one is truly a yes or no we can
even do this number two is just okay but
it's going to take forever
but then we get to number three
and number three is arguably the most
important one of all it's is the quality
any good
in my tinkerings with mpt-30b for
example with a context window up to 16
000 I find that the model itself is of
questionable artificial intelligence
uh likely at the Baseline uh before we
even try to use a larger context for
example here we've got a hallucination
but typically even hallucinations will
at least sort of make sense this one is
just kind of way out there demonstrating
that maybe this model can't even
comprehend what a prime number is or
something using that larger context we
can instead utilize a context window as
a way to really inform the model of our
further upcoming prompts and kind of add
intelligence so to speak or at least
make this information that we want to be
important and known by the model much
more likely to be remembered if it's in
context that it's like much more like
short-term memory or something so for
example I've passed the entire longnet
paper into mpt-30b this paper I'll be
referencing soon and then I've asked a
few questions it it does okay and at
least seems to be smarter than what I
was relying on for the you know from the
base model's intelligence so it does
seem clear that if you have a large
context you can at least probably make
the model Smarter on that specific type
of context by just passing it into the
context I at least like this specific
model mpt-30b for this particular
purpose but even at a context of about 5
000 tokens for this long net paper I was
struggling to fit everything on an 80
gigabyte h100 GPU and that's not even a
third of that you know 16k limit we're
talking about just a 5k context window
we can save some space by running at
8-bit or even 4-bit but this still only
goes so far we have this exponentially
increasing problem but we can really
only like sort of you know maybe half or
a quarter but that's it all right Beyond
This research from Stanford recently has
suggested that even when you have a
large context window that you can use
and somehow process in a reasonable
amount of time the information in the
middle of that context seems to be
remembered much worse than the
information especially at the beginning
but also at the end creating the sort of
u-shape of quality of remembrance here
we can see examples of a variety of
models tested all showing the same sort
of u-shape behavior which suggests that
this is just plain a problem with
attention rather than hey mpt-30bs is no
good this specific one but this other
model with this large context window is
great so all three of those issues
earlier are a problem for us attention
works great up to 2K tokens it can be
stretched to 4K eeked out to 8 and push
to the brink at 16 but that seems to be
where we already are seeing diminishing
returns and quality but then also
processing speeds and memory
requirements act to actually process the
contexts is massive remember mpt-30b at
even just a 5 000 context wants to
slurve up 80 gigabytes of memory easily
and then to generate a couple short
sentences on an h100 at 16 bit it takes
a minute and a half
so big contexts are just plain a problem
they take a ton of memory to use and a
ton of time to process
we need something new which is where we
get things like longnet from Microsoft
research with bold claims of scaling up
to a billion tokens and Beyond maybe
even containing the entire internet in
context and longnet is not the first of
its kind there are many other people
trying to solve this problem because
this is a real serious problem this is
what is stopping everyone from having
larger contacts and everyone wants
larger contexts this is the thing
everybody wants and arguably longnet is
the the one of many in a long line of
attempts going back to probably long
former which was at the end of like
2020. this long net paper for Microsoft
despite boisterous claims of containing
the entire internet in context and
having a billion tokens it is
interesting because it does seem to
solve at least two of those three
aforementioned issues you could
theoretically fit a 1 billion context
length into something like an eight
h100 sxm build let's say that five times
fast and and the actual processing speed
could be comfortable depending on the
parameters that you set for this dilated
attention and it would be comparable in
speed to a Transformer with say 8 or 16k
context so how is Microsoft actually
doing this essentially my understanding
is its attention as we know it but
context is split into segments and
sparsified as needed to fit attention is
calculated in parallel in this way but
in those segments and then it's combined
into a final output you really can just
and that's what they're calling dilated
attention by the way you really can just
tune your exact needs and wants by
specifying segment size and sparsity
in this way I think that long net is
very important because right now we just
don't have a great way to scale out
larger context Windows even if we
weren't having this sort of like lost in
the middle problem
the computational requirements are just
just too great it's literally impossible
and Jensen can only cook up these new
powerful gpus so fast so something like
longnet solves some problems at least
those first two issues but what about
that final nagging issue
even if it fits and runs fast does it
actually work
in the long net paper Microsoft Compares
longnets with dilated attention
perplexity scores to where and by the
way propensity lower is better to a
sparse Transformer and we can see that
in each case longnet is a bit better as
we increase context this paper leaves us
with two major questions though I and I
think probably one is the one that
really matters one complaint I've seen
from people on this paper is that
Microsoft only compared to typical
Transformers up to 32 000 tokens you
know where's the billion token
comparison while I do think Microsoft
could have gone a bit larger than 32k
I'm not sure what model they would have
used without making a brand new one just
for the testing purpose and even if they
did so what we've already seen that
large context attention as we know it
costs way too much to be practical in
any way so in terms of memory
requirements and processing time as well
as just simply quality sure we could
compare longnet giant attention scores
and at least see how does that
extrapolate out but it's it's unclear
you know I guess to to one end we simply
cannot reasonably expect to have a 1
million context window Transformer so
long as attention stays the way it is
today unless somehow we have just a
massive Hardware breakthrough which I
also doubt but then even if we did we
would have the Lost in the middle
problem
now the second question of course is
what about that third problem that lost
in the middle problem how is the quality
while we can process a billion tokens
are we just gonna have that lost in the
middle type of problem again I suspect
we probably will sure we can have a
billion tokens and then segment them and
give them lots of swarcity and stuff it
stuff it even into a single h100 card
but will the quality be any good
dilated attention while slightly better
on average in perplexity when compared
to typical attention still very
obviously and clearly deteriorates at
similar rates to typical attention even
just between the relatively small ranges
of 8 and 32k and I say relatively small
if we're going to say hey we can do this
up to a billion tokens so if you're
already deteriorating significantly
between 8 and 32k
I just have to ask well why or how could
this actually make it even remotely
close to 1 billion parameters or even 1
million parameters
so that question Still Remains because
if you really think about this sort of
dilated attention
at least to me it sounds a whole lot
like okay yeah we're going to segment
and we're going to calculate in parallel
I think that sort of makes sense because
then you would and then you kind of
chain it all together and then you
compute attention one more time I can
sort of see that working but it sure
sounds a whole lot like why don't we
just make attention every nth token
right and it just slowly kind of use
convolutions up
um you know maybe that works but I just
don't you know it's like just imagine a
really simple example of okay well let's
just if we want to fit a billion tokens
we can have attention be every nth token
where n equals one million well okay
that's fine but you're losing a ton of
data you still have to you have to find
some way of compressing attention one
thing is for certain though current
attention has to change before we can
see any Improvement in the realm of
context windows for Transformer based
large language models
that's all for now thanks for watching
let me know your thoughts below and
check out the neural networks from
scratch book at nnfs.io if you want to
learn more about neural networks and how
they work I will see you all in the next
video